we always like to ask about some
upcoming projects I'm just very excited
for Sesame Street and to see what that
turned out to be I have two questions
about that if we could if not it's it's
it hasn't happened yet I hope it does
if if that's the case if you could
answer this if you don't want to it's
totally fine but you've you've stayed
attached to that with many delays for a
long period of time you are very very
busy and oftentimes when that happens
someone drops out so what is it that
makes you want to stay to it stick with
it and hopefully see it through to
fruition if it happens one day oh fear
no
um
well I mean
I don't really make movies that I don't
love
and even even if it's a strange love
even if it's a love that doesn't make
sense to other people and even by the
way if the final product isn't in any
way what I thought it was going to be if
it doesn't spark something
um I I can't I just I don't think I can
do it and so when you read something and
you're genuinely Charmed or it's
something or delighted or it brings you
Joy or it's something that you want to
share with others it's really hard to
step away from things like that that
move you authentically and you know and
this is a funny business like things
movies take 20 years to get made and
um and there is something really really
satisfying about sticking with certain
things and there is something really
great about looking out and saying oh my
gosh I can't believe it for like eight
years I was the only person who
understood this and I really and all
those people who had my back believed
him and so it's just it's a wonderful
story it doesn't always work out
sometimes eight years later you're just
like I think it's time to call it it's a
mixed thing it's a and I'm really lucky
that so far I've been able to have a
career in this industry so I've had all
sorts of different experiences I feel
like I'm rambling and I'm just gonna put
the mic down by knowing someone believes
in a project to that extent will always
up my interest more so than anything so
the fact that you feel that way about it
still leaves me hyped about it I have
but I also want to say that what we do
is highly experimental and you know what
you're saying about if some if
everyone's gonna love everything then
you can question whether or not enough
risks were taken or or whether or not
you played it safe to kind of appeal to
the most the widest possible audience
and if you are interested in filmmaking
as a sort of experimental version of art
there's a really good chance that it's
not going to work and it's a really big
ask of audiences to say I know I know
please please keep coming back because
when it hits we all know what what it
means but it does mean that sometimes
you have to eat some failure and that's
cool too